how many hours would you say you were in
the gym putting in work oh uh
like three probably
our king
it was so amazing to see you on the big
screen
and having that power and representing
females as a king
am i uh sensing feelings
[Music]
well you're right
how was it for you watching on the big
screen oh it was so fun yeah the
premiere was last night and it was
really a dream i i you know i was so
excited to see the movie and to see all
my friends who i made the film with but
i
was so struck by seeing all of the fans
and all of the folks in cosplay and
dresses all the characters and seeing
all the different versions of val like
that was really exciting and such a
dream y'all shut down hollywood
boulevard i know it's what and i'm from
l.a born and raised and i used to go to
those cinemas as a kid like that was a
big treat to get to see a movie at one
of those screens so then to be seeing a
film that i'm in it's not lost on me you
know what a dream that is i have to say
i was amazed by how you looked i know
how much work must have gone into
getting yourself ready for this role oh
right okay what was your workout routine
like heading into the film
um
it was extensive because i was also
coming off i mean it was like you know
the
the part of the pandemic and and i think
like many people i was stuck at home and
i was eating my feelings and
some people probably you know got all of
their angst out in working out and i did
not
i got my angst out and cooking and
eating it um so i was definitely like
you know i had to be pretty
strict and work really hard really
quickly to get into shape
and i was really lucky i trained with a
guy named reggie reginald brantley who
has trained a lot of you know pro
competitors bodybuilding competitors um
but a lot of cardio and a lot of
weightlifting and a lot of just like
diet and and being on a pretty
restrictive diet for a bit and then once
i had like gotten a little bit more into
shape i could
add more and eat more but um
yeah i i i feel really lucky to get to
go through a period of just being tasked
to try to get into the best shape
possible and obviously there's like an
aesthetic thing with like yes building
muscle or being toned but the thing that
felt really exciting is especially after
coming out of a period of being on the
couch a lot to just feel better in my
body frankly and get really strong and i
think as we all get older it's a good
thing just to get strong you just wake
up with less pain which is nice
how many hours would you say you were in
the gym putting in work oh uh
like three probably
i'm like three minutes and i'm done
wow three hours well so yeah like in the
most intense like yeah i would do an
hour of cardio in the morning and then i
would try to do weight training at some
point during the day and then an hour of
cardio like two hours before bed chris
told me that you were the ice bath champ
and now you could make it like a full
three minutes and no one else could we
had a big ice bath there which we'd
rotate through and that was that became
the kind of
the most noise was made in that thing
that was the real test of strength tessa
was kicking my ass now i i've done it a
bit but i'd sort of was keeping my time
in there to sort of a minute too and she
came in first i ended three three and a
half minutes and so then we all have to
try and do three minutes and
yeah this is this is really cool because
you know see they didn't he didn't give
me these props in the moment because i
think he was just trying to beat me at
my best but i wasn't i was just trying
to beat my own personal best uh
in the ice baths but i've fallen off i
do them now but i can't do them for as
long as i was doing them then but it
really is sort of a zen it's really like
mind over
matter which is the interesting thing
you guys really have such an incredible
cast and i love seeing how you guys are
of course on screen then also off screen
i hear that there was a lot of improv
with this film and you guys kind of went
off the cuff in a lot of scenes i mean
all the time that's that's just the way
that i think tycho works and especially
in these movies there's like
most all of it is not on the page and
then you figure out sort of what you
need to say and what we need for clarity
and the truth is a lot of it
probably doesn't ever make it into the
film but i think just to have that sense
of play for the things that do exist in
the film they you could only get there
if you're just
freely allowing what comes to happen and
improv do you like that mode of
operation i do it was something that you
know when we made when i made the first
film it was something i wasn't used to
because i hadn't made a lot of films in
in that style before um
but it's been such a joy and yeah i
really really love it and especially
when you are working with folks that you
trust and and that you love and it's
kind of a safe space for everyone to
just do their best and also their worst
and that and that is yeah that's great
and rare
that's what natalie said it was it's
because who she was with she was able to
be so open it was really fun i mean it's
really it's a completely different
experience as an actor because your
biggest work is to
come and be open instead of like having
kind of preparation and a plan and like
know what you're doing and feeling like
you have control over
your performance um and so it was
definitely a new thing to experience but
i loved it like i i
i wish i could go back and
do do it again because after having had
the experience because it's um it's
like you get so much after you
understand kind of the mechanics of it
that you feel like you want to use that
knowledge
yeah but i mean and also the truth is
like these movies they make us look so
cool and it it feels so cool seeing them
but some of it is like pretty
silly you know and you do have to have a
sense of play in it and it's nice we had
everyone's kids was around because
there's so many of our cast mates have
beautiful children and they'd come to
set and you just like it reminds you of
playing in the way that you would play
as a kid and you don't worry too much
about what you look like or what people
are thinking about you just kind of go
and that's really liberating you don't
get to do that a lot um in in this
business or just in life in general so i
i count it as a privilege for sure you
mentioned the families on set the kids
on set natalie said that she brought her
kids and they were most wowed by taika
on set yeah
what that makes sense because well also
you know when tyka is is doing cork he
has this korg head that's like attached
to
him here and he has this weird like you
know harness thing on and dots on his
face i mean the whole thing and then
he's like also directing it it's a lot
there's a lot happening so what wowed
you most sunset
still
i think i i still feel really wowed by
how incredibly talented everyone is and
i mean like you see all these people on
screen and they are
amazing but all of the people that you
don't see that make the world of the
film the people that build all the sets
and the light and and people that create
the digital world i mean after we shoot
they spend a year to make these films
look the way they look and that's
extraordinary and i think as an actor
especially i mean there's
you know we're on a huge um
studio and you go into every lot and
there's like amazing carpentry and and
and this and all of the folks that do
set design and props and costumes like
you go into these worlds and they're
just extraordinary crafts people and and
and those are the folks that you don't
always you know
think about when you see these frames
but literally the film doesn't exist
without them and so i'm continuously
wowed um by by the incredible work of
the people that make these movies and i
get to make these movies with
[Music]